mitten in der antarktis
meine kabine lief voll wasser trägt ein
kreuzfahrtschiff lag verdammt
und droht in den eisigen fluten zu
versinken
zwar konnte es nicht mehr kommen
ich brauche die maschinen jetzt die
katastrophe naht mann ist vollkommen
hilflos alle mann von bord alle mann von
bord
wir glaubten dass das schiff jeden
moment kennt hat ich dachte ich muss
sterben
154 menschen treiben in eisiger sie
ihrem schicksal entgegen ich dachte das
war's wir werden zusammen gehen
sie hatten keine zwei stunden mehr
es ist früher abend im antarktischen eis
mehr die passagiere an bord des
kreuzfahrtschiffes explorer genießen tag
elf ihre 19 tägigen reise die exkursion
auf dem 73 meter langen schiff ist keine
ausgesprochene luxusreise er eine
abenteuerfahrt zum ende der welt
die 91 passagiere an bord haben bis zu
16.000 dollar pro person ausgegeben und
hoffen auf das abenteuer ihres lebens
iritani ist aus kalifornien angereist
ich wollte schon seit jahren die antrag
des reisen dachte aber dass der
normalsterbliche nicht hin dürfen
sondern nur forscher
turin hollywood kommt aus dem englischen
kent
die explorer war ein wirklich schönes
schiff sie war klein und gemütlich
sobald man an bord kam fühlte man sich
wie zu hause sie war das beste schiff
auf dem ich jemals war
die explorer ist speziell für fahrten in
den polargebieten konzipiert sie hat
einen doppelwandigen rumpf der sie vor
treibeis und schelfeis teilen schützen
soll
das kleine rote schiff wie es genannt
wird kann dahin fahren wo andere
umkehren müssen
man war so dicht am wasser und hatte das
gefühl ein teil der natur zu sein man
guckt einfach und dachte wow besser
geht's nicht
genau deshalb bin ich hier
[Musik]
doch für die mannschaft wirkt der trip
ins eismeer risiken das wetter kann sehr
schnell umschlagen und stürme und raue
see mit sich bringen zudem können große
eisschollen das schiff umschließen und
im schlimmsten fall sogar den rumpf
durchbohren
chris hören ist kapitän und kennt sich
in polar gewässern bestens aus
das problem in der antarktis ist nicht
nur das eis sondern die abgeschiedenheit
und rettungsdienste sind außer
reichweite wenn du da probleme bekommst
bist du auf dich allein gestellt und
muss unter umständen sehr lange warten
bis ihr jemand zu helfen konnte
die männer auf der brücke sind
hochkonzentriert bereit bei einem
plötzlichen zwischenfall schnell zu
reagieren
wie sieht's heute abend aus bis jetzt
gute
kapitän bringt wie man hat das kommando
an bord er fährt seit über 25 jahren zur
see und war viel im eis der schwedischen
ostsee unterwegs
daran werde ich mich nie satt sehen
bild sw enzen ist erster offizier und
stellvertretender kapitän
[Musik]
dahin gefahren wo die anderen
kreuzfahrtschiffe nicht mehr hin konnten
einer der gründe mich für diesen beruf
zu entscheiden man sieht viel und lernt
immer dazu
auf dieser fahrt wandelt die explorer
auf den spuren des entdeckers ernest
shackleton dessen schiff die endurance
wurde im november 1915 auf dem weg zur
antarktis von packeis eingeschlossen
fast 15 monate liegt die mannschaft
hunger und kälte ehe sie sich mit drei
rettungs quoten aus der hoffnungslosen
situation befreien konnte die explorer
scheint wie gemacht für die shackleton
gedächtnis tour ist sie doch das erste
kreuzfahrtschiff das 1970 in die
antarktis vor die reise beginnt in
argentinien und führt über die ford land
inseln und süd georgien zur
antarktischen halbinsel
für den morgigen tag ist ein landgang
auf dem eis kontinent geplant es ist der
höhepunkt der reise für georgi hale und
ihren mann gleich ist es ein ganz
besonderer urlaub
bei meinem mann wurde eine unheilbare
form von blutkrebs diagnostiziert und
wir hatten uns bewusst vorgenommen jede
minute die uns noch blieb so erfüllt wie
möglich zu gestalten
dazu gehörte die antarktische halbinsel
doch der weg durch die eisigen gewässer
ist voller tücken
hier ist der neueste bericht
detaillierte meereis karten und
radarmessungen helfen der brücken crew
einen schiffbaren weg durch die eisige
see zu finden
du guckst nach vorn und ist ständig auf
der hut wie viel eis da wohl noch
hinterm horizont kommt die radare sind
an die offiziere auf der brücke halten
ausschau es gibt einen extra aus kuba
aber manchmal sieht man nicht was im
wasser ist weil es stockdunkel ist
der kapitän hat schlechte nachrichten
ich glaube nicht dass wir es bis zur an
der arktischen halbinsel schaffen nicht
bei dem
eine große enttäuschung für die
passagiere doch kapitän wie man hat
einen plan b penguin island müsste
klappen
da gibt es viel zu sehen
ich sag's den passagieren
[Musik]
penguin island ist eine gute alternative
sie ist nahe der antarktischen halbinsel
und bietet eine beeindruckende tierbild
meine damen und herren ich habe ein
update für sie der kapitän teilte uns an
diesem abend mit dass wir durch
mächtiges mehr eis fahren würden und
dafür wollte er uns warnen
es könnte also lauter werden aber keine
sorge meine empfehlung ohrenstöpsel das
war es dann
später am abend machte in hollywood
einen abstecher auf die brücke
hey kann ich reinkommen immer herein sie
können sich hier hinstellen danke
groß halten
die brücke der explorer ist den
passagieren frei zugänglich für die
passagiere ist das toll denn sie lernen
die abläufe kennen und sehen was
passiert
welches die aufgaben der mannschaft sind
was die offiziere tun und wie sie
entscheiden
mourinho wird sieht wie sich immer mehr
als in den weg schiebt
wir brauchen die scheinwerfer
wir fahren in ein eisfeld
geschwindigkeit drosseln
ich rufe den captain sollte das schiff
in ein reisfeld geraten muss sofort der
kapitän gerufen werden captain wir
fahren in ein eis welt kommen sie hoch
wenn möglich gehen wir dem eis aus dem
weg aber das klappt eben nicht immer
hier ist der kapitän gefragt er hat die
meiste erfahrung
alles klar ich übernehme sie übernehmen
könnten
sieht aus wie einjähriges eis
einjähriges eis ist noch nicht zu dick
und hat damit kommt das schiff thwler
doch etwas anderes bereitet dem kapitän
kopfzerbrechen
die große frage ist immer was für eine
art eismann da vor sich hat die
gefährlichen kleinen gletschereis stücke
sind so hart und kompakt als wären sie
aus beton und möglicherweise steckt man
in gletschereis ohne es zu wissen
5 grad auf backbord bitte
man steuert dahin wo das eis besonders
lohse ist und fährt dann langsam rein
weiter auf kurs bleiben
die explorer muss 15 kilometer durch eis
fahren ehe sie wieder offene gewässer
erreicht
während ihr mann unter deck ist verfolgt
georgie die fahrt von der brücke aus
der kapitän ist heute abend sein geld
wert
ich hatte meine videokamera rausgeholt
um dieses unglaubliche knacken und
ächzen des eises aufzunehmen einfach
fantastisch ich habe mit der kamera
nachhinein eingeschränkt und sah dieses
mächtige eis und was war dass wir
dadurch gekommen sind
als der explorer durch das eis verfügt
ist der lärm und entdeckt ohrenbetäubend
ich wollte unbedingt ein bisschen schlaf
kriegen also hatte ich zum ersten mal
hoch und stückzahl rein gemacht und
wollte fit für den nächsten tag sein
doch in hollywood ist auch auf der
brücke und sie zu wie der kapitän sich
durch das eisfeld kämpft
ich stand im hintergrund und zu
fotografieren
intensives lang schrammen
es geht nur langsam voran man darf den
kurs nur behutsam ändern und lässt das
schiff mit dem eis arbeiten
nach zwei stunden erreicht die explorer
endlich wieder offene gewässer
wir sind fast durch
kurs halten
das schwarze offene meer war schon zu
sehen und ich hatte den eindruck dass
der kapitän dachte okay jetzt noch mit
schwung durchsetzte stück und dann sind
wir in offene meer
absolut unglaublich wie er das gemacht
hat der zieht das durch
cerny liegt in seiner kabine und kann
nicht einschlafen
ständig dieses kratzen und klopfen man
konnte die erschütterungen spüren als es
durch das eis holpert
dann passiert etwas seltsames
meine finger lagen zwischen dem kopfende
des bettes und der kabinenwand dann
wölbte sich die kabinenwand und drückte
auf meine finger
und das tat weh
ich wollte dann meine leselampe am
kopfende anmachen und merkte dabei das
ist nass war also fasste ich an die wand
und da lief wasser runter über meine
finger an sich
jani steigt aus dem bett und tritt in
eiskaltes wasser nicht durch sich dann
in der kabine steht das wasser und der
pegel steigt und jetzt
ich dachte was machen wir als wir aufs
schiff gingen bekamen wir eine
einweisung für die rettungsboote und sie
warnten uns nicht aus versehen den
alarmknopf in der kabine zu drücken aber
ich dachte wann wenn nicht jetzt und
drückte das ding
auf der brücke geht der alarm los
sobald in den kabinen was passierte gab
es auf der brücke ein signal und sie
schickten jemanden runter
wir haben einen passagier alarm
wahrscheinlich wieder falsch anlagen
hier spricht der kapitän bitte schicken
sie den alarm auf ebene 3 100
als sie unten ankommen steht ihnen das
wasser bereits bis zu den knien
ich glaube das wasser kommt hinter der
wand heraus
herten
ich bin ja
das wasser stieg sehr schnell mir war
kalt ich zitterte und wollte da keine
sekunde länger bleiben nachdem ich raus
aus der kabine war und im gang stand
hatte ich keine zeit darüber
nachzudenken ob ich angst habe
schieß los hier ist alles voller wasser
tobias
sagen wir ob es salzwasser ist
wenn ihr süßes wasser ist ist vielleicht
eine leitung gebrochen das ist zwar
lästig aber kein problem das kriegt man
wieder hin doch wenn du salzwasser im
innern schmeckst ist es ein leck
verstanden
lag sicherungs team nach deckt 3 das ist
keine übung
alle passagiere bitte in warmer kleidung
und mit rettungswesten in der penguin
lounge versammeln
[Musik]
als er die durchsage machte wussten wir
nicht was überhaupt das problem war wir
gingen zum sammelplatz wo sich alle sehr
schnell einfanden dort trafen wir den
passagier der den alarm ausgelöst hatte
und der erklärte uns auf
warum bist du nass meine ganze kabine
ist voll gelaufen das schiff könnte
sinken
wie voll gelaufen ist als ich sah wie
schnell die kabine voll lief und wie
schnell das wasser sich auf dem deck
ausbreitete wusste ich dass das schiff
sinkt
der erste offizier peter svensson soll
die situation in den griff kriegen
wir haben ein echtes problem das wasser
tritt rasend schnell ein vielleicht die
bodensicht unruhe ich will hören wo es
herkommt
denn wasser im schiff ist ist das sehr
ernst du willst wissen wo es herkommt
und wie schnell du es stoppen kannst
hast
der verkleidung wir müssen sie auf
machen wir müssten die pumpen holen
das wasser erreichte mir da bis übers
knie das ist beängstigend
und es war eisig ich glaube die
wassertemperatur lag bei minus 1,5 grad
36 höher in der lounge wissen die
meisten passagiere noch nicht wie ernst
das problem wirklich ist vielleicht zehn
leute wussten was da wirklich passiert
die meisten hatten keine ahnung
in der rückschau ist das seltsam dass
kaum jemand in panik gerät oder besorgt
war
denn ihre gene des kabinetts ahnten
svensson und seine männer verzweifelt
nach dem weg
wir mussten roher gewalt anwenden um
hinter die wand zu kommen
wir nahmen äxte und alles was hart genug
war um durch die wand zu kommen wir
mussten die ursache des lecks finden
sie reisten die verkleidung raus sie
hauen die kohle kurz und klein und
währenddessen läuft immer mehr kalt es
an taktisches salzwasser rein
einer von den jungs musste mit seiner
hand nach dem leck tasten und hat das
auch gefunden
ist genug da mal raus merkel ich glaube
ja es ist ungefähr faustgroß
die zeit rennt ihnen davon sie müssen
das loch abdichten egal wie
sie haben dann ein kissen reingestopft
und mit einer spange die verkleidung
gegen das loch gedrückt
es ist ein bisschen als würde man eine
wunde abdrücken um die blutung zu
stoppen
eine provisorische lösung
doch jetzt kann das wasser abgepumpt
werden und der wasserpegel sinkt
wir schaffen das wir gewinnen die
schlacht wir sind aus dem schneider wir
kriegen das hin
darf ich um ihre aufmerksamkeit bitten
der kapitän bringt die passagiere auf
dem aktuellen stand
wasser dringt in das schiff ein ich viel
aber wir pumpen es wieder ab ich werde
ihnen später ein update geben danke sehr
die war auch danach die bar auf ein
schlückchen wäre jetzt echt gut
er erklärte uns dass das wasser raus
gepumpt wird und der wasserspiegel sinkt
kein grund zur panik also einige
unternehmungslustige versuchten
daraufhin die ba zu öffnen das hat aber
nicht geklappt
doch die lage ist ernster als es scheint
das schiff hat sich nach steuerbord
geneigt
peter svensson spürt dass irgendwas hier
furchtbar schief läuft
solche wassermassen können nicht aus
einem so kleinen loch kommen
deswegen dachte ich dass es vielleicht
noch mehr löcher geben könnte
eine stichprobe in anderen kabinen lässt
seine schlimmsten befürchtungen wahr
werden drei weitere kabinen laufen voll
ich muss den captain sprechen sofort das
wasser steigt alle pumpen an bord sind
im einsatz sie kommen nicht hinterher es
wird brenzlig
das wasser tritt schneller ein als wir
es abpumpen können wir können nichts
mehr machen wir können nichts mehr
machen
schlimmer konnte es nicht mehr kommt
in den eisigen fluten des sudans ist das
kreuzfahrtschiff explorer leckgeschlagen
es hat gefährlich schlagseite und droht
zu kentern
das wasser fitschen als wir es anpacken
können wir können nichts mehr machen
verstanden
der kapitän weiß dass die schlagseite
schlimmer wird es ist nur eine frage der
zeit bis die exportierten und dem
dunklen eismeer versinken wird der
kapitän hat keine wahl er muss die
schlimmste durchsage seiner karriere
machen alle mann von bord alle mann von
bord alle mann von bord alle passagiere
zu ihren vorgesehenen rettungsstationen
alle mann von bord alle mann von bord es
war der reinste horror
dann wurde es ziemlich chaotisch die
leute realisierten dass das schiff
tatsächlich untergeht und wir von bord
müssen
doch es kommt noch schlimmer
verdammt
machine-to-machine stoppt die maschinen
explorer sind ausgefallen und das schiff
treibt zurück ins feld ohne antrieb kann
das schiff nicht in offene gewässer
fahren und die rettungsboote zu wasser
lassen
man kann ein rettungsboot nicht auf eis
absetzen es wurde genau wie die
passagiere das packeis könnte die boote
zerdrückt dass eindringendes salzwasser
hat die maschinen lahmgelegt der
maschinenraum ein deck tiefer ist voll
gelaufen und die kraftstoffpumpe die die
generatoren versorgt ist ausgefallen der
erste maschine ist jersey pawlowski
arbeitet seit acht jahren auf dem schiff
jetzt hat er seinen wichtigsten einsatz
gib mir den schlaf
wenn die maschinen ausfallen ist es
schwarz auf dem schiff es gibt kein
licht man kann nichts machen man ist
vollkommen hilflos
in völliger dunkelheit kämpfen die
männer ums überleben
maschinenraum ich brauche die maschine
jetzt ich arbeite daran
pawlowski hat einen geistesblitz er
bastelt eine improvisierte
kraftstoffpumpe zusammen die die kaputte
ersetzt
er hat aus einem abbau auch ein
provisorium gebaut das war eine clevere
lösung um die generatoren mit kraftstoff
zu versorgen tatsächlich war das
entscheidend
geschafft die maschine läuft wieder
[Musik]
gute arbeit schief der kapitän kann das
schiff jetzt aus dem eis manövrieren und
die rettungsboote herunterlassen volle
kraft voraus
die überbrückung dieses systems über
eine technische und seemännische
meisterleistung absolut professionell
geschwindigkeit auf null geschwindigkeit
0 allem an in die rettungsboote jetzt
mit der kapitän setzte einen notruf ab
und verlässt die brücke alle passagiere
und die crew insgesamt 154 personen
gehen von bord
die leute kamen von überall heraus
geströmt
uns wurde nicht mitgeteilt warum wir von
bord gehen muss nun aber wir hatten
angst dass das schiff umkippen würde
weniger auf einer seite wirklich
gruselig
die rettungsboote treiben auf unruhiger
see bis zur nächsten insel sind es 40
kilometer es ist bitterkalt
selbst wenn hilfe unterwegs ist wird es
noch stunden dauern bis sie hier ist
ich dachte das war's wir werden zusammen
gehen mein mann wiederum dem sechs jahre
zuvor gesagt wurde dass er nur noch
zwölf monate zu leben hätte war frei von
solchen gefühlen er wusste genau wie es
in mir aussah immer wenn ich meinen kopf
auf die rettungsweste senken ließ und
schlafen wollte weckte er mich wieder
auf er stellte sich vor mich und
schützte mich vor wind und wasser er
gehe fest davon aus dass wir das
überleben würden
georgi hale hält die irrfahrt mit der
kamera fest
[Musik]
es ist sehr schwer zu beschreiben du
verlierst jeden sinn für raum und zeit
wenn mir jemand gesagt hätte dass wir
schon seit zwölf stunden in den
rettungsbooten waren ich hätte ihm
geglaubt hätte jemand gesagt eine stunde
hätte ich das auch geglaubt es war sehr
kalt wir waren müde und nass und viele
von uns waren seekrank
das boot war voll wasser wir waren von
der gischt durchnässt und es regnete es
war bitterkalt und ich dachte ich muss
sterben
und als wir dachten dass niemals jemand
kommen würde war da ein licht am
horizont und alle sagten da ist ein
licht am horizont
es hat sich so gut angefühlt ich wusste
dass sie nicht mehr weit weg waren es
konnte noch zwei drei stunden dauern
aber sie waren nicht mehr weit
es ist die nord neugier eines von zwei
schiffen die auf den notruf der explorer
reagiert hatten
nach fünf quälend lange stunden in den
rettungsbooten werden alle passagiere an
bord des schiffs gebracht kurz vor
ausbruch eines heftigen polar stroms
die passagiere hätten maximal noch zwei
stunden zu leben gehabt wenn die neue
später gekommen wäre hätte das wohl
keiner überlegt
erst als wen sicherheit waren würde uns
klar wie knapp das war
am 23 november 2007 15 stunden nachdem
ihr leid charlie den alarm ausgelöst
hatte versenkte explorer im frostigen
wetter mehr
doch wie konnte es soweit kommen
[Musik]
dort war früher ermittler der us
verkehrsbehörde ntsb
und arbeitet heute für das liberianische
schiffsregister da die explorer unter
liberianischer flagge segelte muss er
sich nun des falles annehmen keine
leichte aufgabe
alles was ich zu diesem zeitpunkt weiß
ist dass es sich um ein kleineres
passagierschiff hand wird das in ein
eisfeld in der antarktis gefahren ist es
ist mit einem eisberg oder einem eisfeld
kollidiert und ist geflutet worden mehr
ist nicht bekannt die explorer verfügt
über die hohe eis klasse 1a und hat mehr
als 250 mal antarktische gewässer
durchquert was ist also tief durch dann
immer ermittlungen eingeleitet werden
stelle ich keine vermutungen an das ist
bei der explorer nicht anders ich höre
nicht auf das was andere sagen ich baue
auf fakten
ford setzt auf gespräche mit der
mannschaft vor allem mit dem kapitän
captain erzählen sie mir alles woran sie
sich aus der unglücksnacht erinnern wir
fahren durch eis alles läuft gut keine
auffälligkeiten
der kapitän berichtet dass er durch
einjähriges eis gefahren ist und es
keine probleme gab
einjähriges eis ist immer noch heiß da
sollte man ordentlich respekt haben es
ist eine potenzielle gefahr für jedes
schiff man kann die propeller oder ruder
beschädigen oder drin stecken bleiben
aber wenn ein schiff einer s klasse
besitzt und verstärkt ist kommt es da
eigentlich problemlos durch
ich verstehe das nicht das ergibt keinen
sinn das schiff ist dafür konzipiert
doch wie kam es zu dem verhängnisvollen
lag das letztendlich zum verlust des
schiffes führte er war überrascht dass
das passierte er konnte sich nicht
erklären wie es dazu kam das schiff war
für solche fahrten konzipiert und das
eis ja auch nicht sonderlich
dass es zwischen dem einfahren ins
eichsfeld
und die meldungen über einen
wassereinbruch ins brot passiert
das ist die frage
[Musik]
doch noch etwas passt nicht ins bild
warum war es nicht möglich ein nur
faustgroßes loch zu schließen
bei einem faustgroßen loch tritt zwar
wasser ein aber das bedeutet nicht dass
das schiff automatisch verloren ist
ford hat nicht viel ändern weil hastigen
evakuierung des schiffs ist der schiffs
datenschreiber zurückgelassen worden
der schiffs datenschreiber auch wie dior
genannt zeichnet die geschwindigkeit des
schiffs und die ruder befehle auf für
mich wären jedoch auch die
tonaufzeichnungen aus dem steuerhaus
entscheidend
da auch die fehlen muss ford mit den
augenzeugenberichten arbeiten ich werde
mit so vielen passagieren wie möglich
reden alles klar die ermittlungen gleich
in einem puzzle man muss alle teile
zusammen bekommen die passagiere sind
ein puzzleteil und zwar ein
entscheidendes bot ford hat wenig
anhaltspunkte warum die explorer
untergegangen ist doch erhält ein trumpf
in der hand
die passagiere haben fotos von allen
stadien des unglücks geschossen auf die
er jetzt zurückgreifen kann
schau dir das an
sogar mit zeitangabe
bei einigen liegt der exakte zeitpunkt
der aufnahme vor dadurch kann ford den
ablauf des unglücks minutiös
rekonstruieren
kurz nach mitternacht als der
wassereinbruch gemeldet wird
befinden sie sich bereits mitten im
maisfeld
story mir sagte dass sie fotos hat
dachte ich dass es zu schön um wahr zu
sein kann ich reinkam immer herein sie
können sich hier hinstellen
fords glück dorin hollywood hat nicht
nur fotos gemacht sie war auch auf der
brücke als das unglück passierte
möglicherweise kann sie licht ins dunkel
dieser katastrophe bringen sagen sie mir
was passiert ist also ich war auf der
brücke und habe fotografiert
sie zeigte mir ihre fotos und berichtete
mir detailliert dass im steuerhaus
passiert ist
mourinho wird erzählt fort da sie es
anfangs sehr genossen hatte
doch die tiefe sie ins eis welt
vordringen desto wohler fühlte sie sich
stabilisiert
ist stabilisiert sieht gut aus wir
fuhren schneller und das eis schien
blicker zu werden mein bauchgefühl sagte
mir dass hier irgendetwas nicht stimmt
dann kam das schiff plötzlich zum stehen
sie sagte dass es abrupt stehenblieb und
sie beinahe um viel das schiff kam zum
stehen ich wäre fast gestürzt
mourinho wird übernimmt die rolle des
schiffs daten schreibers ihr
erinnerungsvermögen ist beeindruckend
sie kann ford sogar sagen was der
kapitän tat um das schiff wieder in
bewegung zu setzen
er guckt durchs fernglas und sprach
darüber wie man durch eis endlich
manövriert
wir versuchen es noch mal
langsam achter aus langsam machte aus
lotterien kann das schiff nach dem
aufprall zum stehen daraufhin der
kapitän zum steuermann und sagte so
durchbricht mal eis du fährst achter aus
und wieder nach vorn hin und zurück bist
du das eis durchbrochen hass
der kapitän hofft durch die ram bewegung
des buchs das eis zu brechen und die
fahrt anschließend fortsetzen zu können
volle kraft voraus voller kraft voraus
schon oft hat er in seiner 25 jährigen
karriere diese methode angewandt noch
nicht mehr weit wir sind fast durch
als ich auf der brücke war sagt der
kapitän wenn man beim ersten mal nicht
durchkommt muss man es immer wieder
probieren
man nennt das eis rahmen es bezeichnet
ziemlich genau was da passiert man fährt
mit voller kraft voraus und bahnt sich
seinen weg durch schwieriger
eisverhältnisse
ford befragt doch cerny der das leck als
erster gemeldet hatte
zeigen sie mir wo
überall hier in mindestens vier kabinen
steuerbord ja ich wusste sofort dass wir
kennt dann werden
das wasser flutete schnell mehrere
kabinen was angesichts des nur
faustgroßen next seltsam ist sie liefen
alle gleichzeitig voll damit war die
theorie vom faustgroßes loch vom tisch
für mich klingt das er danach das
seitlich aufgeschlitzt wurde
licht an licht an
der zeitliche ablauf ist entscheidend
mourinho wird beobachtet dass der alarm
ausgelöst wurde direkt nachdem das
schiff im eis vor und zurück gefahren
war die passagieren beobachtet wie das
schiff mit hoher geschwindigkeit durch
die großen schollen brechen will sie war
zurecht beunruhigt denn die explorer ist
kein eis brechen dafür war sie nicht
konzipiert sie war ein schiff das
durchfahren konnte aber nur sehr
behutsam
die explorer hatte einen doppelboden
doch die einfache seiten beplankung bot
keinen schutz gegen schweres eis die
ermittler durchforsten die akte des
kapitäns sie wollen herausfinden warum
er trotz all seiner erfahrung ein so
riskantes manöver fuhr
der mann ist sehr erfahren
auf jeden fall gerade im 1 doch dann
stoßen sie auf ein interessantes detail
sie dir das an das war seine erste fahrt
in die antarktis
wer also viel erfahrungen der ostsee
aber nicht in der antarktis und das sind
zwei verschiedene ice typen
teile der ostsee verizon jedes jahr und
schmelzen im frühjahr wieder dadurch
wird das eis nicht wirklich hart in
diesen breiten ist es eine übliche
methode durch das eis zu rammen in der
antarktis wiederum wo das eis über die
jahre wächst und aushärtet kann diese
methode tödlich sein in der ostsee kann
man durch das eis rahmen weil man weiß
wie die bedingungen dort sind man hat
allenfalls einjähriges eis
in der antarktis setzt man nicht zurück
um das eis dann zusammen wenn man auf
größere eisschollen trifft drosselt man
die geschwindigkeit und versucht das eis
behutsam aus dem weg zu schieben
rhythmus herausbekommen was für eine art
heißt die explorer hinein gefahren ist
und wieder ist es ein passagier der ihm
die antwort liefert
schrieb mir dass sie videoaufnahmen
gemacht hatte ich fragte wann und sie
sagte während des aufpralls das wasser
rein lief ich bin fast vom stuhl
gefallen
ich war sehr froh dass ich den
ermittlern mein video material zur
verfügung stellen konnte
das war von unschätzbarem wert für
unsere ermittlungen
die ermittler sichten georgi hales
filmaufnahmen vom moment des unglücks
erfährt euch dieses dicke reisen durch
chef ermittelt ob voll bittet einen
ehemaligen kapitän der explorer um rat
der selbst fast zehn jahre erfahrung in
polar gewässern hat
mit seiner hilfe will er klären ob es
sich wirklich um einjähriges eis handelt
wie captain wie man sagte oder doch um
härtere size dass das schiff beschädigen
konnte
sieht aus als würde er mit fünf knoten
in das eisfeld reinfahren ziemlich
schnell der kapitän ist offenbar
schneller gefahren als es die
bedingungen zulassen
wenn man durch die antarktis fährt muss
man immer wachsam sein das eis ist
mitunter schwer zu sehen manchmal erst
wenn man direkt drauf fährt deswegen
wird man die geschwindigkeit wenn man in
eis gewässern ist
auch die buchfrage liefert den
ermittlern wichtige hinweise sehen sie
sich die flagge an sie fahren in den
wind hinein dass es nicht gut
der wind schiebt das eis vor dem schiff
zusammen und blockiert damit eine
mögliche ausfahrt
während er durchs eis fährt schaut er
nach lücken durch die hindurch fahren
kann doch diese lücken werden immer
kleiner bis das eis so verdichtet ist
dass er nicht anders kann als auf eis zu
fahren
hier können sie bitte anhalten und
zurückspulen
es ist nur schwer zu ziehen aber größe
und form der eisschollen machen die
ermittler stutzig
hier
sehen sie wie dick das eis ist dass es
nie und nimmer einjähriges eis
[Musik]
auf dem video ist zu sehen wie die
explorer sich einer großen eisschollen
ehrt die über mehrere jahre gewachsen
und ausgehärtet ist sie könnte den
seitlichen rumpf mit leichtigkeit
aufschlitzen sekunden später kommt das
steuerbord zu einer kollision
ich glaube wir haben
er war leichtsinnig der kapitän
vertraute darauf dass das schiff mit dem
eisfeld klarkommen würde er lag falsch
als er es für einjähriges eis hielt
wir brauchen jetzt die scheinwerfer
die ermittler kommen zu dem schluss dass
eine ganze reihe von fehlern zu dem
unglück führte
meine damen und herren ich habe ein
update für sie der erste fehler die
entscheidung in das eis hineinzufahren
durch den kurswechsel werden wir heute
nach durch mehr eis fahren es könnte
also lauter werden
in der dunkelheit fast dem kapitän
nahezu unmöglich das eis richtig
einzuschätzen
fehler nummer zwei sein aggressives
fahrmanöver volle kraft voraus volle
kraft voraus im dünnen ostsee eis mag
das rammen erprobt sein doch in der
antarktis funktioniert es nicht
ich habe dass etliche male gemacht man
muss da voll draufgehen
bei dem versuch das eis zu durchbrechen
wurde die explorer seitlich
aufgeschlitzt dadurch kam es zu dem
verhängnisvollen lag und das schiff
kenterte bei
diesen wassermassen war das schiff nicht
zu retten egal was sie versucht hätten
ohne die passagiere hätte ford die
ursache für das unglück wohl nie
gefunden
ohne job der ihn und er wäre es
unmöglich gewesen
viele fragen wären offen geblieben und
wir hätten uns nur auf die crew
verlassen müssen
bei der havarie der explorer wären um
ein haar
154 menschen gestorben
jedes jahr fahren mehr schiffe in die
empfindliche antrag des region die
internationale seeschifffahrt muss mehr
denn je darauf achten dass alle schiffe
und kapitäne auch tatsächlich die
eignung für die fahrt ins eis mitbringen
die explorer ist gekentert weil der
kapitän die falschen entscheidungen traf
und die gefahren der antarktischen
gewässer unterschätzte
das fischerei- und meeres institute
memorial university in neufundland nutzt
hochmoderne schiff simulatoren um
angehende schiffsführer auf fahrten
durch eisige polar gewässer
vorzubereiten
sensation schult mitarbeiter in der
schifffahrt die in besonders riskanten
umgebungen arbeiten wie etwa 1
navigation sie sind weltweit gefragt
hier ist ein geschwindigkeitsmesser er
zeigt 9,1 knoten an aber man sollte
runtergehen ok
ausbilder mcneil arbeitete 37 jahre lang
für die kanadische küstenwache er kennt
sich mit den verschiedenen ice typen aus
und weiß wie er mit ihnen fertig wird
hier zeigt er maria hafner hat wie man
durch ein eisfeld navigiert ihr
ziel ist es zum offenen wasser auf der
anderen seite dieser ansammlung hier zu
belangen
ok fangen wir mit der bahn
[Musik]
der simulator hat eine ganze reihe
verschiedener schiffstypen im programm
die hochauflösende grafik bietet eine
naturgetreue abbildung einer meeres
umgebung mit verschiedenen ice typen
selbst die bewegungen des schiffs werden
simuliert
der simulator ist auf eine hydraulische
plattform montiert die alle sechs
möglichen bewegungsmuster auf simulieren
kann ich ja vier knoten ist das okay das
ist gut
dass einjähriges eis oder älter das ist
ein jährige size
aber in diesem gebiet gibt es auch drei
stücke
treibeis stücke sind stücke von
gletschereis die nicht mehr als fünf
meter über die meeresoberfläche haben
die sind viel schwerer zu erkennen sie
liegen viel tiefer
ein eisbrocken sieht noch kleiner aus
der ragt höchstens ein meter aus dem
wasser aber unter der oberfläche ist er
bedeutend größer er ist selbst bei
tageslicht schwer zu erkennen
wir wissen nicht wie dick das eis ist in
der naturgetreuen simulation schulen die
übungsteilnehmer ihre ice erkennungs
fähigkeiten wenn du eis kontakt hast
musst du den pitch auf null bringen
dadurch trifft desto ohne antriebskraft
des ice
wir arbeiten uns langsam vor bis wir das
eis besser lesen können
[Musik]
das schiff kollidiert mit dem äußeren
rand einer simulierten eisfeld du passt
seine geschwindigkeit an und arbeitest
nicht stückweise vor so kannst du das
schiff besser kontrollieren anstatt ein
großes manöver zu fahren ein teil der
ausbildung ist die leute in unangenehme
situationen zu bringen sie schwitzen zu
lassen die jeweiligen situationen sind
so realistisch wie möglich denn hier
können die leute fehler machen und
lehrgeld zahlen in der realität wo es um
menschenleben geht ist das nicht möglich
andere kurs auf 21 5
wir kommen jetzt aus dem eis raus okay
gut
[Musik]
egal was du für einen fehler machst am
ende des tages ist es eine übung und
anschließend gehst du nach hause wenn du
auf see bist und in gleichen fehler
machst wirst du hoffentlich überleben
und in der lage sein noch mal drüber
nachzudenken
der abschlussbericht vom untergang der
explorer findet auch lobende worte über
das krisen management nun
vor allem des ersten maschinisten hier
sieht losgehen dessen
improvisationsfähigkeit es erst
ermöglicht hat dass die rettungsboote
gewässert werden konnten
erst immer schön ist war der held er hat
es geschafft dass der kapitän weiter
machen konnte
[Musik]
der bericht kritisiert dass der kapitän
überhaupt ins eichsfeld gefahren ist
die entscheidung ins eichsfeld zu fahren
war bestenfalls fahrlässig wenn man es
weniger gut meint war sie rücksichtslos
trotz ihres martyriums macht green
hornet dem kapitän keine vorwürfe
viele haben bei dem unfall lehrgeld
gezahlt
und es ist ein segen dass niemand
gestorben ist ich bin mir sicher dass
der kapitän das schiff nicht versenken
wollte ich gebe ihnen keine schuld es
war ja keine absicht
er hat einen fehler gemacht er hat die
fähigkeiten des schiffs offenbar falsch
eingeschätzt
er ist ein guter kapitän ich würde ihm
mit freuden wieder dienen
ich glaube ich habe nach dem unfall
einen anderen blick auf das leben
bekommen über kleinigkeiten rege ich
mich nicht mehr so auf ich denke dass
ich generell eine etwas entspanntere
einstellung zum leben bekommen habe
ich bin glücklich dass ich noch am leben
bin wenn man eine lehre daraus zieht
dann die dass man sich über kleinkram
nicht so aufregen sollte und genau
genommen ist fast alles kleinkram